[Music]
said wow with jack departing
the twitter board collectively owns
almost no shares objectively their
economic interests are simply not in
line with shareholders uh joining us to
talk to take over battle and musk stance
uh on free speech kevin o'leary
investment investor and venture
capitalist he's also a cnbc contributor
and adam singhola taboula founder and
ceo and adam uh we'll get to i i almost
i think i know where you stand kevin i
definitely want you to to weigh in in a
second i want to i don't know where adam
stands because i'm
i would you when it comes to whether
you're a free speech absolutist
or a you think we need more i love it
content moderation where are you adam
more content moderation or uh or free
speech absolutism
uh well i'm not sure kevin and i uh are
in agreement here but i uh i am
definitely more uh and high on content
moderation i mean i think and i'm
convinced that it's important to live in
a world that our kids make decisions
that are based on something that's safe
for them they're not being bullied we
want a healthy ecosystem of publishers
that can participate and feel safe we
want advertisers to be able to
participate and feel safe and i think
it's actually mission critical twitter
has done a lot of hard work in the back
scene we're all seeing the front end
consumer feed but in the back end you
know there's a lot of hard work to
sustain this church and state to make
sure people feel safe so i think it's
super critical and we need more of it
hey adam do you
will you at least
concede
that let's say that you're based where
twitter is based let's say i think
someone characterized it as swimming
with with a a school of fish that are
that are all the same all the same about
just take for example cultural issues
so they look at content moderation
through this prism they're absolutely
sure and everybody around them is
nodding and it's an echo chamber and
they're all like yeah yeah yeah and they
decide on the content moderation you
don't have a problem with that what
about the the other fish that are on the
other side swimming in an entirely
different school
and i mean it's a private company they
can just appeal to those other fish
but it certainly
you know you if you wanted a public town
hall or public forum you're not going to
get it there
i think the critical decision here joe
is to make sure there's no ceo or any
executive actually that has an opinion
that can make decisions you want to
separate much like much like you know on
cnbc
no you do that by creating a policy you
put it out there publicly so anyone can
yeah we've seen twitter's possible you
separate
you separate the moderators and people
human beings you want human beings that
interact and review things first the
ones they picked were horrible the ones
they picked were horrible and i don't
want them uh deciding for me kevin what
do you think
so the way i'd like to look at this
because this debate around curating
content is not unique to twitter this is
a problem for all social media platforms
and over the last decade almost 10 years
this company's been public and if you
compare its performance
let's talk about investors this is the
most miserable investment you could have
put your dollars into in social media it
has totally
lagged all its other competitors never
grew anywhere near as fast as google or
facebook or instagram or even tick tock
that just cleaned it out almost right
away in a matter of months you have to
ask yourself that the rotating suite of
executives have come through this thing
and all the stock options issued over
the last nine years have created
virtually no value for the shareholder
now the best way to look at this is you
gave them a decade why not get the
whacking stick out and just start all
over again and that's what elon musk is
proposing the biggest risk for
shareholders here whether you believe in
the free speech issue or not
is if musk goes away then they're back
in the same miserable place they are now
you know there's dante's hell at the
very bottom of that is twitter this has
been a horrific place to try and grow a
business it needs change it needs the
whacking stick it needs everybody
cleaned out of there and i think frankly
if you ask me about free speech and who
should be cancelled who's not the reason
this thing is underperformed is they've
tried to do this curation by canceling
voices and losing millions of followers
this is an abysmal performance
kevin i don't disagree that this is a
company that is underperformed i think
that that that is clear and whether elon
can perform better i think is a
a fair question he of course doesn't say
that he wants to even run it for any
economic purpose he's actually been
explicit about that the question on the
free speech piece though is
you know at some level you either have
to decide that you're completely
laissez-faire in which case twitter and
all these social media platforms if they
approached it that way would be littered
littered with pornography would be
littered with snuff films would be
littered with uh terrible language we
would be littered with with all sorts of
stuff that would make it completely you
know if you think these places are
hellscape now think about what they
would look like if there was no
moderation just think about it
andrew all of that already exists on the
internet an uncurated way and people
seem to be surviving all of that exists
now you know when you start to try and
figure out who should have a voice and
who shouldn't you're stepping on the
basic principles of free speech in
america and that really doesn't sit well
with the majority of the population even
free speech as much as i think anybody
and believe that if you want to go
online and have a a perspective or a
view you can have it the question isn't
can you put that message out there the
question is does the does the uh
distribution mechanism the companies
where it's hoping hosted need to
distribute that to
you know millions of people to 10 people
or somewhere in between that's the
question and that i'm not sure is
actually about free speech at all
okay but you have to impose these rules
on every single social media platform if
you decide that you're going to allow
for this it has to be ubiquitous across
the entire internet and i think that's
going to be impossible to do the cost of
free speech the cost to society is
allowing the lunatic fringe to have a
voice and that's always been the case
back to when they were writing
newspapers by hand you got to get over
that andrew you have to realize that the
lunatic fringe has a voice it's horrible
if you don't like their opinion
pornography i don't want my kids seeing
a foul language or terrorism
then you use the tools of the internet
to to stop those url sites as you do now
in your home you have those tools why
can't twitter put those tools out why
doesn't facebook do more tools why
doesn't google do the same the point is
you can't curate the entire internet
it's not going to work you can provide
tools and that's what twitter should do
but back you know you've got to ask
yourself it's horrific what this
company's done to their shareholders i
weep like a baby for them i wouldn't
touch this stock however if elon musk
gave me a piece of the deal if he took
it over on the debt stack or the equity
i'd back him because of executional
performance on everything he touches the
rest of this board and those employees
have done a horrifically bad job i think
they should be fired adam what do you
think
i think kevin is mixing two different
topics that are both import both
important but have nothing to do with
each other the free speech is just a
question about do we as people you know
of the universe support any platform
that has distribution to hundreds of
millions of people and the pipes and the
infrastructure exist to push a message
out to millions of people which did not
exist 50 years ago and does not exist on
the open internet because that's the
fundamental difference facebook and
twitter have the responsibility to
moderate
those pipes that infrastructure is
what's different between opening the
browser and going to a website of your
choice let's put that aside the reason
twitter is not where it can be which i
would argue is an opportunity for them
by the way is because the advertiser's
success as it comes to performance
advertising if you compare amazon and
facebook and google to twitter there's a
gap there this is a separate topic then
there's a question of can twitter solve
this problem can twitter be a place
where millions of businesses small
businesses to big brands be as
successful on twitter as they are on
amazon google and facebook if the answer
is yes this company is a 50 billion
dollar revenue company not five if the
answer is no then it doesn't matter
right that is a separate topic and that
is an opportunity for twitter
shareholders
kevin
well there's no question there's an
opportunity for shareholders but it
doesn't involve this board or probably a
majority of these employees i think you
have to reboot this company get the
spatula out from the sky scrape it clean
and start again they've tried so many
times to try and figure this out i want
to point something out to everybody here
in terms of advertising dollars whether
you like curated content or not
all of this content that twitter puts
out is not seen on the twitter platform
you take the tweet you put it up on the
cnbc screen and you distribute it and
you collect the advertising dollars the
big problem with twitter is they're
simply a wire service they haven't grown
a base that they can monetize and that
requires new management you made them
famous all the networks of television
when trump used to tweet his stuff out
nobody saw it on twitter they saw it on
your network and that's why it's so
broken now i think elon you know
probably bring in new fresh ideas i'd
definitely back them because i've made
money with him never made any money with
the twitter people they suck in terms of
returning capital back to shareholders
and that's horrific you got to think
about it after 10 years yes weak
performance time to change let's make
the change let's move on i'm backing him
if i can
so adam would would you try to uh to
level the playing field at all
at twitter let me let me make an example
i think you've seen cable tv right we
don't need to mention any names but
you can watch
one view of the world and
half the people that like that view
watch that view
and then you can watch the other view of
the world and another half like to live
in that echo chamber and they
you know they talk to all their friends
that they're in the same tribe and they
all not oh my god that others other
people they're just oh and on both sides
you hear that
i i view twitter the same way you think
twitter should
i mean they can run it however they want
kevin makes the the point that maybe
that's one of the reason for the
underperformance
but
do certain people just have to go to a
different social media outlet to get a
fair shake is that okay with you if you
alienate half the people
with the your content moderators at
twitter because they're all they all
have the the same mo in the same thought
set
at twitter they're all aligned on one
side of things and what's there for
people that have the other side
yeah i think i think it's a real
challenge and and you know problem that
you're raising um you know the whole
dynamics of echo chamber and seeing more
of what i know and more of what i follow
is a real problem and i'm not suggesting
by the way social networks have resolved
that i mean i think and i've spoken here
on this show many many times over about
the challenge of social networks and how
concerned i am about social networks
versus the open web and journalism and
you know free speech as it exists with
human beings on the other side of it so
don't you know it's important to know
how strongly i feel about the other side
and specifically the open web i do think
there's a problem there all i'm saying
is when it comes to safety and that's so
much about you know echo chamber i think
it's critical tesla has a seat belt and
you would never buy that car without a
seat belt and that that seat belt
matters it matters everywhere and by the
way ellen would never have taken that
two-boat out so that's all i'm saying
i'm not saying it's perfect um and i
think there's a lot more to be done well
i'm saying if this seat belt goes off
there's a real problem be great to have
algorithms
be great to have actual fair algorithms
to dictate things but we know that even
even the algorithms could be skewed with
the writer of the algorithms so i don't
know kevin it's
it's a slippery slope it's a slippery
both sides have
good points that can be made uh you are
you're just let it fly kevin i know
which
no
i i why does everybody fear change so
much what's wrong after you give someone
a decade to get performance or
executional skills they can't deliver
you simply fire them what's wrong with
that that's what's wrong that's
capitalism it's a good thing
if you like that video where you see my
next one don't forget to click right
over here and subscribe